[Music]
good evening welcome at tucker carlson
tonight just about 24 hours ago the
President issued a sweeping
declassification order
he gave us Attorney General William Bar
broad authority to find and release any
documents related to domestic
surveillance spying by American
intelligence agencies over the course of
the 2016 campaign
you'd think everyone would like this you
think it would qualify as Donald Trump's
least controversial decision as
president everyone in Washington says we
love transparency democracy dies in
darkness The Washington Post reminds us
every morning even now members of
Congress are calling for the impeachment
of the president because portions of the
Moller report were redacted
let's see everything they're telling us
okay let's do that
the president suddenly appears to agree
with them let's see everything so how
did the left reacts when he suggested
that not well watch this in the end this
is all part of a pattern of politicizing
our Justice Department instead of
allowing justice to be done I know it
sounds like the onion but it's true it
just also may bring a tear to your eye
to quote a former high-level DOJ
official this is a grotesque abuse of
the intelligence community this is is an
attempt by the president to let the
women and men of the intelligence
community know FBI agents and others
know that if you investigate him he's
going to come after you write that bill
Barr and others are going to come after
you third investigation of the same
material just designed to further the
propaganda against the mohel
investigation politicizing the Justice
Department that's what they're concerned
about they're telling us it's funny
politicizing the Justice Department
didn't appear to be a major concern when
FBI agents spied on and then slandered
Carter page an entirely innocent
American citizen when another two FBI
agents were caught talking about an
insurance policy against Trump becoming
president and then promising to stop
that wasn't politicizing the justice
department either according to them
neither was the fired head of the FBI
leaking memos to the press through a
sympathetic left-wing law professor to
make a political case none of that was
politicizing the Justice Department but
an attorney general declassifying
documents that already exist that he had
nothing to do with creating well now
we've gone too far
CNN trotted out former Director of
National Intelligence and serial liar
Jim clapper to let viewers know that
really this could be dangerous
concerning because there's already been
so much information Declassified already
that particularly in the point in the
form of the Moller report and the
previous indictments going back to our
original intelligence community
assessment that we did in January of 17
so I wonder what else is going to be
declassified that what risk jeopardizing
sources methods precisely he's concerned
that the FBI's methods might become
public and that's exactly what we need
to know a lot more about the FBI's
methods the FBI is a lot more power than
any single government agency its agents
can legally break down your front door
and shoot you it's investigations can
destroy your life even if you're
innocent it's happening to a lot of
people recently so the FBI absolutely
must be above suspicion if you sincerely
cared about preserving our democracy as
they claim they do then you would
immediately disinfect the FBI with
sunlight but James clapper is no
interest in doing that neither does the
rest of official Washington the only
principle they care about is
self-preservation and they will say
anything in its service congressman Adam
Schiff of California responded to the
declassification order this way quote
while Trump Stonewall's the public from
learning the truth about his obstruction
of justice Trump and Barr conspired to
weaponize law enforcement and classified
information against their political
enemies the cover-up has entered a new
and dangerous phase this is on American
end quote
got that declassifying information is
now a cut
her up its unamerican keep in mind this
guy is the chairman of the House
Intelligence Committee Adam Schiff is a
complete nutcase his allies in the media
though are something more subtle than
that they know that cover-up isn't a
plausible way to describe
declassification it's laughable so
instead they're going with the term
distraction why that's distract and
deflect it's very good distraction
distract from a day of very bad news an
effort to distract distract as usual
you're watching projection at work a
distraction yes we're familiar with that
concept for two and a half years we
listened to their absurd theories about
Russian collusion the goal was to
distract us from the implications of the
2016 election and more broadly to keep
Americans from noticing what is
happening to their country the dying
small towns the needles and garbage
flooding the big cities the overrun
border the Middle Eastern Wars that
persist for no reason
they'll grotesque and growing income
inequality on the coasts the rise of
China abroad etc these are actual
problems in some cases they're
full-blown crises they need solutions
and serious people to think about those
solutions every day this farce about
Russia and cover-ups continues is
another day that America gets weaker and
more divided after a while you begin to
conclude it must be intentional there's
no other explanation for it